il faudra modifier la Constitution et je
demanderai aux Français de se prononcer
sur un tel texte est-ce que oui ou non
ils sont d'accord avec le regroupement
familial il est temps que le président
Vienne a des méthodes plus démocratiques
et mon élection je réhabiliterai le
référendum le référendum est une
promesse de campagne présidentielle cela
montre le fait que les hommes et les
femmes politiques sont déboussolés
depuis 2005 il y a plus de référendum le
référendum semble aujourd'hui faire
l'unanimité et pourtant depuis 2005
aucun président n'y a eu recours
normalement le référendum c'est un grand
moment de sincérité c'est à dire le
président et le peuple
c'est binaire donc c'est spectaculaire
constitutionnellement elle doit d'abord
passer par l'Assemblée nationale puis le
Sénat ce jour-là quel est donc l'avenir
du référendum cet outil démocratique
est-il difficile à manier et le pari
politique parfois trop risqué la classe
politique française reste assez
traumatisé par l'échec du référendum de
2005 ça engendrer une profonde
turbulence politique c'est le moment
fondateur de tout ce qui se passe depuis
dans notre vie politique depuis cette
date
je préfère une consultation populaire à
un blocage du pays
[Musique]
10 référendum ont été organisés depuis
1958 de Gaulle qui veut avoir un lien
direct avec les Français fera de cette
consultation populaire une arme
politique majeure
à 5 reprises il interrogera le peuple
sur des décisions essentielles qui
engagent l'avenir du pays
moins de 4 mois après son retour au
pouvoir c'est par un premier référendum
que le général de Gaulle va faire
adopter la nouvelle Constitution
le 4 septembre 1958 le général de Gaulle
soumettait au peuple français le texte
de la Constitution qui allait devenir
l'acte de naissance et la charte de la
Cinquième République
et c'est sur la très symbolique place de
la République qu'il présente son projet
[Applaudissements]
le mandat exceptionnel
d'établir un projet de Constitution
nouvelle et de le soumettre à la
décision du peuple
nous l'avons fait
l'exécutif est renforcé
le président sera désormais la véritable
clé de voûte des institutions tel est
l'esprit du projet proposé aux Français
la très grande méfiance du général de
Gaulle en 1958 mais dès 1946 en réalité
c'est une méfiance à l'égardée
parlementaires et à travers sa méfiance
à l'égard des parlementaires c'est une
méfiance à l'égard des partis politiques
le chef de l'État doit être au-dessus
des contingences politiques au-dessus
des parties pour le général il y a au
fond l'état d'un côté et l'État qui a un
chef lui et le peuple c'est les deux
poules essentielles et il faut donc que
le chef de l'État régulièrement demande
la vie du peuple
[Musique]
je vous demande de répondre oui
[Applaudissements]
pendant qu'il parlait alors la place
était très surveillée mais derrière dans
les rues adjacentes il y avait des
opposants mais en milliers
[Musique]
les adversaires de la Constitution en
1958 ils sont principalement hostiles à
ceux qui apparaît comme une figure
présidentielle potentiellement
extrêmement forte la crainte du monarque
républicain
[Musique]
les premières heures du scrutin se
pressaient devant les yeux l'Algérie va
être à 83%
Fernandel s'enfermait dans le secret à
Marseille
[Applaudissements]
et Yves Montand voté par correspondance
à Lyon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 10h du soir les dernières urnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au ministère de l'Intérieur un immense
tableau comptabilisait les résultats
sous les yeux de Monsieur suspel de
Monsieur Malraux
[Musique]
à
80% le plus important de tous les
référendums qui ont eu lieu sous la 5e
République c'est le premier c'est celui
qui a touche qui permet de tout changer
mais je pense qu'au fond c'est à l'usage
qui s'est aperçu que c'était un
instrument de gouvernement et notamment
à l'occasion de la guerre d'Algérie
c'est une journée inoubliable que vient
de vivre Alger
mettre un terme au conflit algérien
c'est une priorité absolue pour de
Gaulle dès son retour au pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
pour y parvenir il organisera deux
référendum en 15 mois en janvier 1961
puis en avril 1962
les Français étaient lassés de voir
leurs enfants allaient se faire tuer en
Algérie et de Gaulle le sentez bien ces
référendum c'était le moyen de consacrer
au fond par un vote populaire la
politique qui menait et de la consacrer
contre les
ultras il fallait conduire
progressivement une opinion publique qui
sous la Quatrième c'était pour une bonne
paraly à l'idée du maintien de l'Algérie
française la conduire vers l'idée de
l'autodétermination et finalement
finalement de l'indépendance et il a
besoin pour mener sa politique
algérienne qui marque tout de même un
changement de cap par rapport aux
positions qu'il avait adopté en 1958 il
avait besoin du soutien populaire
française français nous voulons que 1961
soit l'année de la paix rétablie ce
problème d'Algérie altéré terriblement
la vie politique française donc il
fallait s'en débarrasser vite le plus
vite possible et les gens l'ont compris
pourquoi pensez-vous qu'il faut voter
c'est celle de voir de tout le monde et
puis tous on a certainement tous
quelqu'un en Algérie et moi j'ai mon
frère et c'est normal que qu'on essaie
de faire quelque chose et comme vous
avez 20 ans que on se sert de Gaulle
comme guide et qu'on est heureux de le
voir dans les bonnes circonstances et de
l'applaudir et bien dans les mauvaises
ou dans les moins bonnes on est là aussi
avec lui on vote oui avec lui je sais
que on doit voter pour de Gaulle de
voter pour la paix
mais exactement quoi
ça permet d'aller plus vite parce que
alors même qu'il continuait à y avoir
des oppositions dans au sein de la
représentation parlementaire
l'organisation d'un référendum rend
incontestable l'action du général de
Gaulle
[Musique]
en vérité ces deux moments-là ont été
fondamentaux ils lui ont redonné une
légitimité dans ce qu'était une
politique prodigieusement difficile à
conduire compte tenu de la violence des
passions de la dimension de l'enjeu
l'heure de l'apaisement arrive-t-elle
enfin
l'heure de l'apaisement avec l'heure de
l'espérance une espérance que chaque
Français va sans doute fixer avec le
bulletin qu'il déposera dans l'urne du
référendum
le fait que 90% des Français approuvent
le référendum d'indépendance de
l'Algérie en avril 62 c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire parce que ça
transforme ce qui pourrait paraître
comme un échec formidable la France doit
quitter l'Algérie comme une victoire
c'est la victoire de la France la
journée du 8 avril 1962 a créé une
situation irréversible en Algérie elle
est d'une importance exceptionnelle dans
l'histoire de la République
[Musique]
de Gaulle vie c'est il sentait bien
qu'après la guerre d'Algérie terminée se
poserait la question de savoir ce qui se
passerait après lui
presque un an après l'attentat au has
qu'il avait visé sur la route de
Chaumont le général de Gaulle a une
nouvelle fois servi de cible à ses
adversaires déterminés
un groupe fanatique qui le haïsait pour
avoir fait la peur d'Algérie sans les
prix à sa personne et le hasard a fait
que de Gaulle a survécu du même coup
il a souhaité tirer parti de cette
événement pour expliquer au peuple que à
n'importe quel moment la vacance du
pouvoir la vacance du à l'Elysée le
président de la République pouvait
intervenir qu'il fallait se préparer
mon propre septaina ou si la mort ou la
maladie
l'interrompait avant le terme du général
de Gaulle a profité quand même de
l'événement qui faisait prendre
conscience aux Français que le général
de Gaulle pouvait disparaître du jour au
lendemain qu'est-ce qui se passerait
dans les institutions de la République à
ce moment-là il sait qu'il n'est pas
éternel le général de Gaulle et 4 et lui
aucun homme politique n'aura la
légitimité historique qui est la sienne
donc il aura besoin de quoi le prochain
président ou plus tard la prochaine
présidente éventuellement il aura besoin
d'une légitimité démocratique qui est
celle de l'élection d'un président par
suffrage universel direct il avait cette
idée là depuis très longtemps en tête et
sans doute il avait hâte de pouvoir la
mettre en oeuvre mais néanmoins
l'attentat du picamar lui offre j'allais
dire presque une occasion inespérée cet
attentat du petit-camar qui ne l'a
décidé à passer à l'action et puis de
Gaulle était stratège il a senti que
c'était le moment le président de la
République sera dorénavant élu au
suffrage universel le général annonce
qu'il va y avoir ce référendum et
l'Assemblée nationale vote une notion de
censure la seule motion de censure votée
de toute la Cinquième République qui du
coup renversent le gouvernement
pour la pensée est attaque mais que cet
assemblée n'est pas assez dégénéré pour
renier la République
c'est ça nous ne sommes pas dégénérés la
République est ici et par ailleurs elle
est au Parlement c'est le Parlement qui
est le fondement de la République et pas
une aventure personnelle c'est tous
débat qui est derrière le référendum
faut pas oublier que c'était aussi un
instrument qui avait été utilisé sous
l'Empire plébiscite donc ça avait un
parfum quand même de césarisme
parce qu'au fond depuis de la Seconde
République qui avait vu l'élection du
prince Louis Napoléon Bonaparte puis
ensuite le coup d'État dans la culture
j'allais dire démocratique française on
se disait surtout pas faut éviter à tout
prix l'élection d'un président par le
peuple puisque c'est l'élection d'un
séditieux
nous amène à nous opposer et bien comme
il est naturel le pays tranchera
de Gaulle choisi avec l'article 11 de
contourner le Parlement de poser la
question directement au français plutôt
que d'utiliser l'article 89 qui impose
de passer d'abord par les deux
assemblées pour réviser la Constitution
cette décision va provoquer un violent
débat juridique et politique
évidemment pour les hommes politiques de
la Troisième République
ublique guerre
et qui se qui s'appuie les insistent
tous évidemment sur sur la violation de
la constitution de Gaulle n'a pas soumis
ce projet
référendum à l'Assemblée nationale comme
en principe il aurait dû le faire il est
allé à sa manière je ne sais pas si de
Gaulle c'est dit je viole la
Constitution ça n'est pas grave je ne
sais pas s'il en était conscient j'ai
dit finalement je vais passer par là
parce que mon objectif c'est que cette
réforme aboutisse et c'est le seul
chemin qui est à ma disposition pour le
faire à la fin des années 60 nos
professeurs de droit constitutionnels
nous abreuvait de ce débat et je me
souviens d'hommes extrêmement
respectable qui enchaîne tenait des
propos d'un antigolisme mais absolument
hallucinant sur ce thème il n'avait pas
le droit d'utiliser l'article 11 pour
réformer la Constitution puisqu'il y a
un article dédié l'article 89 nul ne
peut douter que s'il s'en était tenu à
l'article 89 contenu de l'État d'esprit
des deux chambres il n'aurait pas abouti
à cette
solution disons en tout cas que de
Gaulle a dit plusieurs interlocuteurs
écoutez on peut me critiquer mais cette
constitution je la connais bien c'est
moi qui l'ai faite
de chacune de celle
de chacun de ceux qui me leur a donné
ne sera la preuve directe
de sa confiance et ne son encouragement
et là voilà en quelques phrases en
quelques mots il va convaincre les
Français le pouvoir législatif n'aura
qu'à plier les genoux ah c'est vrai que
personne ne se risquerait aujourd'hui à
faire ce qu'a fait le général de Gaulle
à l'époque en même temps c'était de
Gaulle c'était une autre époque mais oui
c'est un coup de force pendant ce temps
les rotatifs débiter les planches de oui
et de nom oui ou non le président de la
République sera-t-il élu par tous les
citoyens si la réponse est positive elle
transformera la vie politique de l'État
en réalité ça n'est pas tant la
procédure qu'on reproche au général de
Gaulle en 1962 ce qu'on lui reproche
c'est l'objet de la réforme
ce que chacun est bien conscient que en
décidant qu'à l'avenir le président de
la République sera élu au suffrage
universel direct bien le président ainsi
élu aura une légitimité
extraordinaire et cette légitimité
extraordinaire risque de faire basculer
le régime vers une monarchie
constitutionnelle un régime résolument
présidentialiste voici donc le général
de Gaulle confirmé au pouvoir à une
heure ou une crise ne pouvait avoir que
de fatals conséquences
certains juristes même ceux qui avaient
critiqué la procédure on dit qu'après
coup le fait même du oui massif à cette
proposition avait en quelque sorte
rétroactivement
validé le principe à partir de 1962
touchant
tout change d'abord en termes de
légitimité de la figure du président
retourne et on dépasse un interdit dans
la culture politique française c'est
interdit c'était justement que le
Président de la République soit élu par
le peuple en 62 il décide qu'on a changé
d'époque et on change de régime mais
après 68 il sait que c'est encore une
autre époque qui est en train de se
dessiner
[Musique]
après plusieurs autres villes aussi
différentes que Rome Berlin Ouest ou
Varsovie l'agitation étudiante s'est
manifestée à Paris
mais 1968 embrase la France le pays est
paralysé le pouvoir violemment contesté
de Gaulle et surpris et bousculé par
cette révolte française et française
avec l'accord du président de la
République
qui s'adressera à vous dans quelques
jours
j'ai rendu l'université à ses maîtres et
à ses étudiants le référendum de 69
c'est d'abord pour de Gaulle la
conséquence de Mai 68 et de juin 68
10 ans ça suffit que clamer les
manifestants le typhon de l'émeute est
passé sur le quartier latin et la France
tout en dire paralysée par les grèves on
a été bouleversé en juin la majorité
Gauliste remporte largement les
élections législatives anticipées mais
le général veut regagner lui-même la
confiance des Français
[Applaudissements]
alors une nouvelle fois il organise un
référendum avec deux questions l'une sur
la régionalisation l'autre sur la
réforme du Sénat il se trouve que moi
j'étais à Quimper le jour où le général
a proposé ce référendum nous devons
soumettre le projet au peuple
revoit encore la scène où il était sur
la place de Quimper sur un petit tertre
il y avait des gens en fureur il est tas
de manifestations et ça on a oublié
parce qu'au fond on a gardé du général
de Gaulle une certaine image qui est une
image quand même d'unité nationale
[Applaudissements]
dans l'immense transformation à partir
de 68 il était détesté
[Musique]
il était déjà un peu avant par la gauche
mais moi j'ai ressenti personnellement à
une un désir de se débarrasser du
général général de Gaulle sans tête très
bien qu'il y avait une usure une usure à
son égard il était suffisamment lucide
et il voulait certainement vérifier si
cette usure était profonde était réelle
même vis-à-vis d'un vieux président de
la République qui jouait le jeu de la
réforme comme le général de Gaulle
appuie toute sa présidence sur le sur le
rapport au peuple il juge nécessaire de
de remettre en jeu cette légitimité de
la réponse que le pays fera à ce que je
lui demande
va dépendre évidemment
soit la continuation de mon mandat soit
aussitôt mon départ c'est un référendum
très golien
au sens où comme en 1962 mais d'une
manière beaucoup plus éclatante il met
son mandat dans la balance et donc il
dit très clairement aux électeurs qui
vont avoir à répondre par oui ou par non
que si le nom l'emporte il partira notre
partie appelle
les Françaises et les Français à
répondre non
ce référendum est immoral comment
voulez-vous répondre par une seule
réponse un oui ou non à plusieurs
questions différentes faut pas oublier
que Mitterrand dans un livre célèbre le
coup d'état permanent le comparer à
Franco et même à Hitler donc ça allait
quand même très très loin la campagne
des gaullistes est difficile le général
est âgé de 77 ans et pour beaucoup de
français Georges Pompidou apparaît comme
le dauphin naturel
sait que finalement Pompidou qui a
montré des qualités indéniable pendant
la crise de Mai 68 peut prendre le
relais donc évidemment l'élément
dramatisation que le général va
introduire en posant la question de
confiance
un peu
quand à Valéry Giscard d'Estaing il
prend clairement ses distances avec de
Gaulle et avec le projet soumis au
référendum
avec regret mais avec certitude je ne
l'approuverai pas
c'est élégante
votre nom il dit pas je voterai contre
il dit Jules de la prouve pas avec cette
son style particulier
en prenant cette distance nettement avec
les intentions du général maintenant il
est toujours soutenu jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie qui n'avait pas voté non qui
s'était
il avait voté blanc si je suis désavoué
par une majorité
d'entre vous que ce serait aussitôt
d'exercer les fonctions
placer à cet endroit là et les Français
peuvent décider de le retirer enfin de
le révoquer et d'une façon
constitutionnelle
il a poussé l'exercice référendaire la
cérémonie référendaire vraiment jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'ultime et puis la réponse du
peuple sera oui le pouvoir est usé ça
faisait en effet plus de 10 ans que le
général de Gaulle était au pouvoir et
c'est un référendum qui s'est conclu par
le nom monsieur
le projet de loi référendaire n'est pas
adopté
pour ma part
si vous me permettez ici de donner une
note personnelle
j'éprouve une grande tristesse en
songeant au départ de celui qui demeure
plus que jamais le plus illustre des
Français le matin je me demandais
si la terre allait tourner normalement
je me rappelle j'étais je suis sortie
dans la rue presque en ayant peur on est
en se disant il me semblait que le grand
parapluie demain était fini cette
dimension tragique ou en tout cas cette
dimension de profondeur nous manque
aujourd'hui dans le débat politique
français mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est
quelque chose oui de shakespearien les
grands titres de la Poste new-yorkaise
les voici de Gaulle le dernier jour
de Gaulle kit les Allemands disent
d'abord que c'est un événement
considérable les Allemands ne
comprennent pas pourquoi le général de
Gaulle a mis en jeu ses fonctions
présidentielles s'en aller à la suite
d'un référendum perdu ça authentifié
sous son parcours démocratique enfin ça
montrait que qu'il avait lui aussi une
conception de la démocratie mais quand
même il en a beaucoup souffert c'était
le dernier volet finalement de son
[Musique]
au nom du Conseil constitutionnel j'ai
eu l'honneur de proclamer Georges
Pompidou résidant de la République
française
j'ai eu le privilège de déjeuner à
Collombey à la fin de décembre 1969 en
accompagna mon père que de Gaulle avait
souhaité invité j'en ai gardé le
souvenir d'un homme d'une grande
sérénité on a évoqué ce qui allait être
le sujet
du référendum suivant c'est-à-dire
l'entrée possible du Royaume-Uni dans la
Communauté européenne il pensait que
l'Angleterre n'était pas mûr pour entrer
dans le marché commun pour contribuer à
la naissance d'une vraie identité
européenne donc nous lui avons demandé
s'il pensait que Pompidou continuerait
dans cette ligne a refusé l'entrée il
nous a dit non non non une résistera pas
[Musique]
faut-il ouvrir les portes de l'Europe à
quatre nouveaux pays dans l'Angleterre
j'affirme que oui général de Gaulle
avait été très clair quand même sur son
opposition à l'entrée du Royaume-Uni
dans dans l'Europe donc pour délire le
général de Gaulle peut-être fallait-il
en passer par le référendum au fond
c'était sa première liberté de se dire
c'est quand même impensable que
l'Angleterre fasse pas partie de
l'Europe il y a aussi la volonté de
donner un visage plus ouvert que le
général de Gaulle vis-à-vis de la
question vis-à-vis de la question
européenne et de l'entrée de nouveaux
acteurs dans l'Europe
là il s'agit de savoir si on élargit ou
pas donc c'est quand même une vraie
transformation si ça dix c'est presque
le doublement des membres et c'est la
première fois qu'il y a un élargissement
à l'époque l'entrée de la
Grande-Bretagne dans le marché commun
était
largement approuvé par le pignon c'était
tentant évidemment de poser la question
avec l'idée que d'abord qu'on ne risque
rien sur le référendum qui a
été de la part du Président
c'est la division de la gauche Pompidou
c'est le chef de l'État par conséquent
il a qu'à faire ce qu'il lui plaît sans
à chaque instant consulter les électeurs
c'est vrai qu'après de Gaulle le
référendum change il y a une conception
aussi assez politique quand même du
référendum qui est intervenu
c'est-à-dire que le référendum est
devenu un outil politique quand il a été
utilisé en général pour diviser
l'opposition les socialistes et les
communistes sont à ce moment en pleine
discussion pour le programme commun qui
va être signé en juin 1972 le référendum
intervient en avril 72 le sens de nos
affiches c'est d'inviter la population
française a refusé de jouer avec les
tricheurs à refusé de voter le 23 avril
donc il y a un calcul politique
Mitterrand va essayer de résoudre
appelant à l'abstention pour éviter un
OUI à Pompidou qui aurait consisté à
casser probablement les négociations
avec le Parti communiste en disant non
tous ensemble vous avez le moyen le seul
moyen de porter un coup efficace contre
le gouvernement de Monsieur Pompidou
contre sa politique ne trouverez pas de
bulletins blancs
alors il vous restera soit à le préparer
chez vous bulletin blanc soit à vous
abstenir
soit à faire comme cela rayer l'un des
bulletins il y a un appel très fort à
l'abstention dans l'opposition au
référendum et à Georges Pompidou c'est
un peu le piège d'ailleurs dans lequel
Pompidou tombe malgré lui
marché Georges
a voté c'est à ce moment que se font
tous les calculs qui permettront à
partir de 300 bureaux de vote de savoir
comment tous les Français ont voté les
Français ont donc ratifié l'entrée de la
Grande-Bretagne j'ai trois autres
candidats dans le marché commun les
résultats du référendum ont toutefois
quelque peu déçu les partenaires de la
France notamment du fait des abstentions
oui le huile l'emporte sans problème
mais la mobilisation est moindre et on
voit au fond que la passion qu'il y
avait autour de la question de confiance
ayant disparu les Français vont montrer
un engouement plus modéré vis-à-vis de
l'instrument référendaire on a le
sentiment que
que français
allongeur et faire un air
et ni Valéry Giscard d'Estaing ni
François Mitterrand dans son premier
mandat de recours au référendum
[Musique]
retour à Matignon pour la cérémonie de
passation des pouvoirs entre Jacques
Chirac et Michel Rocard je devais durer
que quelques minutes elle aura duré
environ une demi-heure sur le Piron de
l'Hôtel Matignon mais je le regarde
accompagne maintenant Jacques Chirac
le référendum de 88 c'est un référendum
Rocca on peut le dire mais acceptez bien
sûr par Mitterrand il s'agit de rétablir
la paix civile en Nouvelle-Calédonie
alors qu'il y a eu des drames
épouvantables auparavant en particulier
celui de la grotte d'Ouvéa au moment de
la campagne présidentielle de 88
mesdames
pas un jour ne s'est achevé sans que mon
action et mes pensées ne soient tournées
vers la Nouvelle-Calédonie François
Mitterrand confie à Michel Rocard quand
il arrive à Matignon ce sujet que Michel
Rocard connaît très très peu et Michel
Rocard va se donner corps et âme jusqu'à
passer des nuits de négociations pour
qu'on arrive aux accords de aux accords
de Matignon qui donneront lieu ensuite à
référendum
il y a quelques semaines la poignée de
main entre les deux hommes juste avant
que Michel Rocard adresse un message au
calédonien reprenez des espoirs
une page nouvelle va pouvoir s'écrire
malheureusement ce référendum est marqué
par un taux d'abstention exceptionnel
puisque il y a 63% d'abstention ce qui à
l'époque ne s'était jamais vu dans
aucune consultation mais 80% de oui et
ce qui compte c'est ceux qui acceptent
de voter dans une élection donc
l'objectif a été attein et la paix civil
a été restaurée en Nouvelle-Calédonie
durablement les Français sont allés
énormément voté pour ce référendum mais
quand vaut aujourd'hui la crise
géopolitique et se féminin dans cet
endroit là du du monde donc c'était un
c'était finalement un référendum dont on
n'a peut-être pas saisi toute la portée
sur le sur le moment
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes j'ai signé ce
matin le décret qui soumet à vos
suffrages le traité d'Union européenne
ou Traité de Maastricht le traité de
Maastricht d'abord un traité qui crée
quelque chose de nouveau l'Union
européenne qui va donc modifier
l'architecture des traités européens et
donc là il se dit on va abandonner la
monnaie nationale c'est une grande étape
de la construction européenne l'Europe
va monter en puissance il faut y
associer le peuple qui compte c'est la
campagne référendaire et cette campagne
référendaire a été très très
intéressante c'est à dire que on pensait
au début que les Français allaient pas
du tout s'intéresser à cette matière si
aride et finalement c'est devenu un
débat passionné les Français avaient
envie de s'intéresser à l'Europe et nous
avons tous ressenti ça je pense en
particulier grand débat de la Sorbonne
qui était très spectaculaire
asseyez-vous
c'était un événement médiatiquement
exceptionnel
un président d'abord devant cartouche 5
français je sais pas exactement combien
il s'était donc il s'est exprimé
longuement avec eux bonsoir Roger vous
avez quel âge 62 ans je suis receveur
honoraire des postes monsieur le
Président je suis gaulliste oui et vous
allez
voterai non j'aimerais savoir dans
l'harmonisation européenne comment
l'État pourra se priver de la manne et
qui va payer pour la France vous ne
pouvez pas nous laisser mourir
l'Europe de la communauté soutient
l'agriculture et le 20 septembre ce sera
pas la fin de ce combat ce sera le début
on voit que c'est un homme qui est
galvanisé par la conviction quand même
qu'il y a un enjeu
important pour la mienne et puis pour
lui-même aussi parce que il faut pas
oublier que à partir de 1900 du tournant
de 1983 l'Europe c'est quand même le son
son principal projet puisque le reste au
fond c'est c'est un peu fracassé et
François Mitterrand le savait dès
l'époque il savait que c'était la fin et
qu'il fallait certainement
contribuer j'allais dire à réussir sa
sortie à sculpter son image il est
d'extraordinairement affaibli
politiquement
la droite va remporter un triomphe au
législatif de 93 donc il veut prendre
une grande initiative politique François
Mitterrand pour montrer que son pouvoir
n'est pas entamé vous savez monsieur le
Président que beaucoup de gens vous
accusent d'avoir évité la voix
parlementaire qui paraissait simple une
ratification simple pour transformer ce
référendum en une sorte non seulement de
plébiscite personnelle mais aussi
peut-être un bon moyen de diviser encore
une fois l'opposition je vous pose cette
question
sérieux c'est l'Europe qu'il faut
maintenant plébisciter ces choses dire
que j'aimerais voir publicité publicité
il joue extrêmement gros parce que si il
échouait à cet égard cette volonté qu'il
avait eu d'être un homme
européen de construire
l'Europe c'était une dominante de sa vie
politique toute entière et il
concentrait ses efforts très largement à
ce moment-là sur cette finalité à
l'époque il veut se référendum pour
qu'il y ait un lien presque charnel
entre les Français et puis cette
puissance technocratique mal comprise
que l'Europe donc ça c'est le grand
dessin de François Mitterrand mais il y
a aussi un petit dessin c'est souvent
comme ça avec François Mitterrand et ce
petit dessin évidemment c'est de diviser
la droite hier soir sans jamais le
nommer Chirac s'est adressé à Pasqua à
qui il reproche de mélanger en jeu
européen et arrière-pensée de politique
intérieure j'ai décidé de voter oui en
toute lucidité
sans enthousiasme mais sans état d'âme
bien entendu c'est un oui alors il vote
oui et moi je vote non on voit bien
Jacques Chirac qui décide de soutenir ce
référendum et puis de l'autre côté
Philippe Seguin Charles Pasqua qui sont
dans qui sont dans le camp du nom et qui
quelque part décide de venir un peu les
souverainistes de ce courant de pensée
il a parlé longtemps très longtemps
Philippe Seguin 2h30 de réquisitoire
anti-mastricht devant une assemblée
étonnamment nombreuse pour une deuxième
partie de soirée l'Europe qu'on nous
propose n'est ni libre ni juste ni
efficace
1992 et littéralement l'anti 1789
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis président de la République
monsieur le ministre
il voulait ses gains sur et pas et pas
Philippe de Villiers par exemple c'était
une façon pour lui de s'engager et de
montrer qu'il n'avait peur de rien qui
n'avait pas peur de son opposition il y
a beaucoup de Français
qui sont acquis à l'idée européenne et
qui ne peuvent accepter ce traité de
Maastricht je pense que c'est votre cas
c'est probablement mon cas probablement
seulement plus que probablement
pas excessif mais un peu shakespearien
dans ce moment-là puisqu'on savait que
Mitterrand était malade pendant
l'enregistrement est obligé de subir des
soins de sortir sa peau évidemment elle
était spectateurs ne le voit pas on
s'aperçoit on a eu cette subterfuge pour
que ça ça n'apparaisse pas une partie
d'ailleurs des partisans d'une autre
trouvait que ses gains étaient trop
polis avec le président et qu'il était
respectueux du Président je me réserve
monsieur président de la République
jusqu'à la fin de notre discussion et ça
aurait été l'adhérentieux vis-à-vis de
vous de conclure trop tôt
et lui dit qu'il avait été très
handicapé dans l'attaque à l'idée
justement de s'en prendre à quelqu'un
d'aussi malade je souhaite que la France
ne limite pas sa diplomatie
au passage obligé par la communauté lors
de ce débat on comprend bien qu'il y a
un vrai débat sur le fond intellectuel
passionnant envie de Seguin c'est tout
sauf un homme médiocre on peut être
d'accord ou pas d'accord avec ces avec
ses arguments mais en tout cas il se
passe quelque chose ce soir là je pense
que les Français sont fiers de leur
dispute
que ce jouet là quelque chose
d'essentiel pour Mitterrand pour son
image et aussi pour la France et pour
l'Europe le traité de Maastricht le
permettra je vous remercie je n'en ai
pas la même lecture je suis président
les arguments du coup ont été de très
haut niveau dans cette période et c'est
ça qui doit rester dans une campagne
dans des campagnes électorales c'est ce
qu'on souhaite c'est que les arguments
soient au niveau des enjeux et je crois
que le débat de septembre de début
septembre
1992 à 17 jours du référendum
effectivement était de ce niveau là le
président se rétablit normalement du
temps de l'opération qu'il a subi il y a
cinq jours il devrait quitter l'hôpital
Cochin aujourd'hui et reprendre ses
activités après une brève convalescente
un président applaudit et souriant
[Musique]
des hommes
d'états vous avez le niveau pour avoir
une dispute intellectuelle de très haut
niveau leur randonnée envie d'aller
voter de se positionner sur un débat
très aride
[Musique]
le oui finalement ne l'emporte que
d'extrême justesse 51% de 8 49 % de non
Mitterrand qui était un combattant
jusqu'au dernier moment il aurait aimé
certainement que ça soit plutôt à 54
55%, mais il se réjouit de ce dernier
grand combat politique qu'il a gagné
[Musique]
c'est très forme du quinquennat c'est un
référendum sous contrainte il était il
est à part se référendum parce que c'est
un référendum dont Jacques Chirac
n'avait pas envie
sous une forme sous une autre serait une
erreur et donc je ne la trouverai pas il
a toujours pensé qu'il était que le
septennat faisait partie de la
Constitution engolienne il a toujours
fait partie des gens qui ont pensé qu'il
fallait justement faire septennat pour
que le président soit dominant par
rapport à une majorité qui pouvait
changer on est en cohabitation le
Premier ministre de l'époque Lionel
Jospin a fait savoir que il était plutôt
favorable à une proposition de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing Giscard d'Estaing
relance spectaculairement le débat en
posant une question
sur la réforme du quinquennat
faire le quinquennat c'est une obsession
chez lui et je pense souhaite cette
réforme j'ai indiqué au président de la
République qu'il était souhaitable
d'engager rapidement cette réforme afin
qu'elle soit définitivement adoptée
avant la fin de cette année ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il s'est créé un climat ou
on a fini par se persuader que cinq ans
c'était plus démocratique que 7 ans
et à partir du moment il s'est dit
Jospin veut un quinquennat Giscard je
suis pas le moins poisonné avec ces
gens-là Jacques Chirac ne veut pas se
fragiliser et Jacques Chirac là-dessus
va agir avec pragmatique j'ai décidé
d'appeler les Français
à se prononcer par la voix du référendum
sur la réduction de la durée du mandat
présidentiel en reprenant ce référendum
à son compte il s'empare du débat l'idée
c'est de ne pas subir alors le risque ce
sera pas le nom ça ne sera pas le nom
mais ce sera le taux d'abstention record
à un référendum
en effet les Français ne se sentiront
absolument pas concernés par cette
réforme du quinquennat qui est pourtant
une réforme bigrement importante il y a
eu l'inversion du calendrier dans la
foulée pour mettre les législatives
juste après la présidentielle et du coup
des législatives juste derrière la
présidentielle ne font que confirmer le
scrutin présidentiel je pense qu'on
s'est pas rendu compte des conséquences
que pouvait avoir le quinquennat sur la
vie politique française l'hyper
présidentielle la question aussi de
l'inversion du calendrier avec une
majorité majorité parlementaire quasi
automatique après l'élection
présidentielle la non possibilité d'une
cohabitation alors les politiques
n'aiment pas la cohabitation mais la
cohabitation c'est un peu comme le
référendum c'est-à-dire que ça permet à
un moment de débat de disputes canaliser
il y avait
[Musique]
si un éventuel conflit il ne peut plus
se résoudre que dans la rue d'ailleurs
c'est un peu ce qu'on a ce qu'on a vu
récemment le quinquennat a modifié les
institutions de la Cinquième République
à modifier la relation entre le
Président de la République et le Premier
ministre a modifié la façon dont les
Français jugent le rôle du président de
la République qui considère maintenant
comme une sorte parfois de super Premier
ministre qui s'occupe de tout il y a eu
presque forcément
une certaine présidentialisation du
système non pas au sens américain du
terme puisque il demeurait un premier
ministre responsable mais une
concentration du pouvoir 50 et si court
dans la personne du chef de l'État donc
on est sur des sur des tons qui
ajoutaient à l'esprit du temps et à la
rapidité des moyens de communication etc
font que la vie politique c'est
considérablement rétréci depuis le
depuis le quinquennat
fondateurs l'Union est passé aujourd'hui
à 25 membres cette constitution veut
donc organiser un nouveau fonctionnement
pour répondre à de nouveaux besoins de
sécurité d'emploi juridiquement c'est un
traité en traita souverain qui ne
remplace pas les constitutions
nationales mais c'est vrai qu'il
ressemble à une constitution
ce référendum là il a d'abord été d'une
campagne extraordinairement forte qui a
marqué
l'affaiblissement des partis politiques
souvenons-nous de cette campagne à peu
près tous les observateurs
tous les intellectuels tous les
journalistes tout la classe politique la
plus visible était en faveur de oui
l'Union pour un mouvement populaire à
une position et elle dit aux Français
c'est le oui je considère que c'est le
oui qui s'est avancé je considère que
c'est le oui dites de nouvelles
espérance de traiter le Parti socialiste
est pour le oui
l'UMP est pour le oui évidemment
normalement c'est les deux grands partis
mais c'est considéré comme précisément
très choquant ce mélange de la droite et
de la gauche dans le oui
UMPS le balancier la droite la gauche
qui se font la courte échelle et
finalement ça a nourri toutes les
critiques anti-systèmes il y a 37 ans il
était évacué de force de la Sorbonne
aujourd'hui Daniel cohn-benditi revenait
aux côtés d'un ministre de droite pour
défendre la Constitution européenne
mais non je veux plus t'entendre
maintenant ça donnait l'impression aux
citoyens qui avait une entente que les
choses se décidaient sans eux on a
décidé pour vous et on pense mieux que
vous la campagne référendaire du
référendum de 2005 à au-delà même d'une
déconnexion entre l'opinion et les
élites je crois révéler vraiment une
fracture entre deux générations
l'Europe face à la Chine face au monde
et là un témoignage et une question on
constate que de plus en plus
d'entreprises françaises c'est ce
délocalise à l'étranger notamment
l'industrie textile et moi je me demande
en quoi la Constitution va nous aider à
ne pas perdre nos emplois
je voudrais d'abord simplement
rappeler que un principe simple c'est
que l'union fait la force
Jacques Chirac sous-estime l'usure par
rapport à Jacques Chirac lui-même et
c'est un Jacques Chirac on le voit très
bien dans le débat avec les jeunes qui a
perdu la main Serda de Jacques Chirac
avec les jeunes qui restent je dois dire
le modèle absolu de l'effondrement de la
fonction présidentielle telle qu'on a pu
le voir il faut dire aussi que Chirac
avait du subir des questions des jeunes
qui portaient sur tous les sujets sauf
sur le la Constitution européenne et le
traité qui évidemment ça l'a légèrement
désarçonné nous avons une jeunesse nous
avons un peuple qui a lieu tout de même
fier d'être français il peut avoir
l'ambition d'être un conducteur
et qui risque de se mettre à la remorque
il y a des gènes à la télévision je vous
comprends plus je vais vous dire très
franchement je ne le comprends pas et ça
me fait de la peine il dit son chagrin
aux jeunes il leur dit au fond qui te
pensent de travers ça
le message de cet échange avec les
jeunes voilà il ne fait même plus le
service minimum
et quelque part il libère les forces de
l'anti-ciracisme ces spectaculaires la
campagne de 2005 elle va complètement
dériver il y avait une espèce de
dramatisation absolument incroyable il y
avait des figures de l'ennemi qui
réapparaissaient le plombier polonais
l'électricien roumain d'ailleurs une
certaine xénophobie qui n'était pas
simplement le propre de la droite de la
droite mais aussi de la gauche de la
gauche
pour la constitution beaucoup des mots
qui ont été
identifier en 2005 comme des mots
européens le déficit démocratique le
caractère trop technocratique la
déconnexion avec les attentes de
l'opinion
une législation européenne qui va
beaucoup trop dans le détail et qui se
préoccupe de la taille des chenilles des
tracteurs plus que des vrais problèmes
finalement ce sont des critiques que
depuis 2005 on fait sans arrêt à l'égard
des institutions nationales on sait les
Français sont pas du tout anti-européens
en revanche il voulait ils avaient
peut-être une autre idée de l'Europe on
se souvient alors on est aujourd'hui ici
au Conseil constitutionnel on se
souvient de la position courageuse
d'ailleurs de le rendre fabus à l'époque
au Parti socialiste qui était pour le
nom à ce traité constitutionnel européen
en répondant non ça permettra de
réouvrir le dialogue c'est pas du tout
les murs devant passer fonder ça veut
dire qu'on va se remettre autour d'une
table pour aboutir à une meilleure
constitution qui permettra d'aller vers
une Europe puissante et solidaire il y
avait aussi dans ce débat après
référendaire une petite musique qui a
été utilisée par les adversaires
de la Constitution européenne en disant
de toute façon ne vous inquiétez pas
vous pouvez dire non sans crainte au
référendum puisque de toute façon il y a
un plan B qui est dans les cartons et
qui va immédiatement être sorti
bonsoir Valéry Giscard d'Estaing fait
campagne pour le oui mais à sa manière
il dit ne pas vouloir rentrer dans
l'arène politique mais juste faire une
explication du texte qu'il a supervisé
alors
le père de cette constitution qu'il a
présidé la convention qu'il a rédigé
c'est une blague
il existe pas
et donc cet argument du Plan B n'était
pas sérieux pour ceux qui défendaient le
modèle européen c'est à dire il
n'imaginait pas que l'opinion pensait
après un tel travail de rédaction d'une
Constitution européenne que l'on avait
pris soin d'avoir gardé dans les cartons
quelques formules alternatives qui
pourraient être réutilisées clé en main
si par extraordinaire les Français
disaient non
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
nous avons le choc du nom au référendum
de 2005 qui a construit un autre clivage
politique le clivage classique c'est un
clivage le peuple contre les élites qui
fait que le référendum est un peu perçu
comme une machine à fabriquer du nom et
à cette volonté qui est de plus en plus
fréquente dans la vie politique
française dans la vie politique de nos
démocraties du vote protestataire du
bras d'honneur fait aux gens d'en haut
comme ça globalement on fait un paquet
cadeau et on envoie un bras d'honneur
peut-être que le refus de ce référendum
et d'abord un refus de l'unanimisme de
la classe politique française et de la
classe médiatique plus le diplôme
s'élève plus le week gagne plus le
revenu est fait plus le nom est massif
c'est-à-dire c'est une vraie coupure
entre la France populaire et la France
des élites intellectuelles ou aisées la
France aisée Neuilly votre 80% de oui
mais le Pas-de-Calais votre a presque
70% de nom
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui se souvint
normal qu'il démissionna regardez on en
est aujourd'hui
on a plus de bipolarisation on a une
quadri polarisation certains même dit un
espace politique divisé en cinq familles
et le désordre le désordre il est venu
largement par les référendum de 92 et
2005 sur la question européenne ça
engendré une profonde turbulence
politique c'est le moment fondateur de
tout ce qui se passe depuis dans notre
vie politique depuis cette date vous
avez
majoritairement rejeter la Constitution
européenne
c'est votre décision souveraine et j'en
prends acte un autre inconvénient de
l'échec du référendum de 2005 c'est le
traité de Lisbonne c'est à dire que
ce qui avait été rejeté par le peuple
en gros a été en gros repris par un
traité adopté par la voie parlementaire
doit
être Nicolas Sarkozy qui a été élu
président de la République en 2007
n'avait pas caché durant sa campagne
électorale que c'est ce qu'il ferait
mini traité peut-être mais grand
spectacles ce matin dans le prestigieux
monastère de Lisbonne
Sarkozy a ensuite décidé de ratifier le
traité de Lisbonne mais sans passer par
la voie référendaire et ça c'est quelque
chose qui qui est marqué dans l'esprit
des Français parce que quelque chose
c'est cassé à ce moment là je pense
légitimement une partie importante des
Français peut considérer que bah à quoi
sert notre nom si en fait vous faites
rentrer par la fenêtre ce qu'on a fait
sortir par la porte c'était pas du tout
anticonstitutionnel et même contraire au
principe de la démocratie mais ça a été
politiquement ravageur
[Musique]
la classe politique française reste
assez traumatisé par l'échec du
référendum de 2005
et ce traumatisme et même sans doute
encore conforté par l'issue du
référendum britannique sur le brexit il
y a là maintenant la conviction que
n'importe quelle question posée à
n'importe quelle question poser des
Français répondrai par rapport au
président de la République et aux choix
qu'ils ont de le maintenir ou s'en
séparer pour au fond acclimater le
référendum il faudrait le
détrésidentialiser que ça n'apparaisse
pas uniquement comme une arme du
président et que donc les électeurs et
davantage leur mot à dire il faut
trouver les moyens de qui est davantage
de dialogue entre les citoyens et le
pouvoir politique ça peut passer la
convention citoyenne en est un exemple
par des assemblées citoyennes tirage au
sort des discussions des délibérations
du Parlement renouvelée pour rediscuter
du texte de loin c'est le référendum
d'initiative partagée qui est prévu à
l'article 11 de la Constitution et qui
pour le moment n'a jamais été mis en
œuvre peut-être qu'un jour un candidat
ou un homme politique c'est vrai et il
viendra expliquer très clairement quels
sont les voix pour faire un référendum
nouvelle manière justement pour
réconcilier les Français avec leur
politique le référendum ne manquera pas
d'être utilisé à nouveau c'est vraiment
une pièce centrale de la Cinquième
République reste évidemment à ceux qui
en ont la maîtrise à le manier avec
ductilité avec finesse avec habileté et
aussi finalement avec efficacité du
point de vue de l'intérêt général
[Musique]